mr shaps we're told that the omicron is
everywhere yet all of a sudden we're
seeing a lot of these rules being
removed are we not letting down our
defenses a little bit too early
no definitely not uh this was always
brought in on a temporary basis and it
did its job we since bringing in the the
red list and then these additional tests
managed to get 13 million extra jabs the
booster jab in people's arms so it
served a purpose obviously omicron is
global it's worldwide everybody has it
now the proportion that comes in from
overseas is completely uh is minuscule
by comparison with the numbers uh that
are actually here so um it's now
widespread and uh in a sense omicron
testing has outlived its usefulness so
we're able to withdraw it from uh
international uh travel uh today uh
domestically of course and carry on
sorry
but that's omicron what about other
variants
by doing this we are potentially adding
loads of other variants in without
testing people before they come to the
uk
well because it's global um we're just
as likely to perhaps have a variant here
we saw that last year with the year
before now with the kent variant also
called alpha
so of course a variant can can occur
anywhere this country does do more
genomic sequencing that's when you find
out that what the variant might be than
any other country in the world so we're
still carrying on that massive
sequencing program we'll carry on doing
that because if you get a positive
lateral flow test after you've traveled
and that is the one test that remains
you must take a lateral flow test by day
two um and if you do get a positive then
that needs to be
pcr'd on the nhs and sequenced so we've
still got that protection in place but
we think this is proportionate a lot of
jobs depend on travel a lot of jobs
depend on tourism and we need to keep
these uh measures in line
with actually what's going on with
omicron around the world which is is
everywhere now it's the predominant uh
strain of coronavirus
not everyone's convinced although the
welsh government health minister said
that she was making the changes
reluctantly uh and the stress that the
welsh government was still advising
against all but essential international
travel why do you think they're not
concerned
yeah look it's always been for the
different devolved administrations
around the uk to decide as far as i'm
aware actually the whole of the uk is
going to be moving on this um together
so these rules will apply um everywhere
and these are judgment calls it's
absolutely uh right to say but but i do
have to say the idea that somehow the
united kingdom is is safe and secure but
if you travel outside of our borders uh
then you know somehow it will be you
know it's a dangerous world out there um
i think sort of belies the truth which
is that omicron is everywhere around the
world we've got very significant testing
in place and i don't think any country
does more testing
than we do per head of population so for
example on tuesday this week
i saw there were over 2 million
coronavirus tests which took place um
and so we you know we keep a very very
close eye on these things but you know
uh people still need to be able to get
around and see a family perhaps
elsewhere in the road in the world
business needs to be done elsewhere and
as i say
many uh we we have pretty high levels of
coronavirus um here so it's not like if
you go abroad you're necessarily going
somewhere with higher levels you may
well be somewhere with lower levels so
we just didn't see the reason to keep
what we're always temporary measures in
place for a moment longer
than was useful and in a sense they just
outlived their usefulness when it comes
to international travel
do we have a shortage of tests
no we don't uh when we get another
spokesman yesterday said that changes
were to make the best use of our testing
system at a time of high prevalence
slightly suggests that that
there's a certain amount of of
prioritizing yeah no that was
specifically in reference to uh not
requiring to do a pcr test if you're
asymptomatic and you take a lateral flow
you no longer need to confirm that with
a
pcr test so that was in reference
something slightly different and yes it
is true to say that we want to make sure
that we're focusing those tests on
critical workers on the front line uh
as for example with transport workers or
with health workers to make sure they're
available so we don't want to over test
for no reason but remember the travel
tests were always provided by the
private sector and that single lateral
flow that's still required will still be
a private sector uh test um but we've
got a huge amount of testing um
available as i mentioned we tested two
million in a single day on tuesday
and
and there are tests available for people
who need to get pcr tests uh lateral
flow supply uh is is very much available
sometimes delivery of those tests is
proving uh challenging and we're
increasing the number of delivery routes
available through the royal mail and
elsewhere as well
could you just clarify the rules on
testing for us and the advice seems to
be that if you have one of the three
main symptoms
that you should get a pcr otherwise not
now this is confusing quite a lot of
people because a lot of people with
omicron have aches and pains and not
necessarily a temperature and a cough
should they just do a lateral flow test
yeah that's right so um just to clarify
this if you have one of the main
symptoms that they're listed on the nhs
website um then by all means booker a
pcr test for other people who are
perhaps going about their normal lives
but maybe feel they'll be in a position
where they'll meet vulnerable people
that's where the lateral flow tests are
available i know a lot of people over
christmas myself included taking lateral
flow tests before going to see my
elderly parents and that's good practice
and it helps to protect everyone in fact
in my family
my my eldest son took a test had
absolutely no symptoms whatsoever and
found he was positive and then had to go
and self-isolate for for nine days until
he got uh two days of negative uh
lateral flow tests so that's the purpose
of lateral flow tests particularly good
where people are asymptomatic and it can
find people who who've got cases but pcr
tests where you are symptomatic that's
that's the message
and it seems to me that the current
message from the government generally
seems to be that we are just going to
have to live with covert as you were
saying you know
it's not the case that there's a big bad
world out there we have a lot of it in
the country um but there's a a lot of of
messages coming from the nhs from staff
and we have this report out today about
pressure on the nhs
and they feel that actually living with
it
is just not possible that we are
reaching a crisis point in the in the
nhs what do you say to that
we've always known in dealing with
omnichrome and this is where our plan b
has been in place that we are uh if you
like always trying to find the right
compromise between going too tight on
restrictions lockdowns and let's face it
they have a lot of costs uh connected
and monetary costs obviously to the
economy but also to people's jobs also
for people's mental health
of these lockdowns
and then again not wanting
our hospitals to be overrun and this is
where i think the plan b has been shown
to be the right approach so far
we we know that uh that
there are hospitals with critical
warnings at the moment that that doesn't
seem to be like it's going swimmingly
for them
yeah so uh there are 137 uh trusts there
are 24 which are uh critical uh it's not
entirely unusual for hospitals to go
critical over the winter often with
things like the flu pandemic but there
are very real pressures which i
absolutely
recognize and we know what it's like
when these hospitals are under pressure
my dad was in hospital this time last
year when there were 40 000 people in
hospital with coronavirus and the
pressures were very real this year we've
got 5 000 more doctors
10 000 more nurses in place uh and it's
very important that we do provide all
those uh resources and and we've we've
we've provided an extra 5.9 billion
pounds to hospitals a 36 billion pound
catch-up program uh as well
but i do absolutely recognize those
pressures as i say what we want to do is
steer the country through the omrichrom
uh wave and i think so far plan b is
shown to have been the right way forward
not shutting down the whole country yet
again with all the costs of people's
mental health uh and elsewhere uh but
making sure that we're providing the
extra resources uh to hospitals uh
unfortunately in terms of those extra
resources
in terms of those extra resources a
report out from mps today uh saying that
nhs waiting lists which are already huge
are to double by 2025
huge numbers uh in the northeast
especially
what is your solution to that
yeah i mentioned the amount of money
that we're putting into tackling those
waiting lists so we've got a 5.9 billion
catch up for 36 million that i that i
mentioned um it's one of the reasons why
we took what most people would accept
was a difficult decision but nonetheless
i think worthwhile one uh last year
which is to say that we will
be having that uh national insurance
rise in order to pay uh in part for
catch up on the number of operations and
routine procedures which because
we've now been tackling coronavirus for
what is it nearly two years uh have by
necessity in some cases not been able to
to take place we want to make sure that
we catch up with that we're putting
record sums into
our nhs we love the nhs we want it to be
able to function i think most people
watching a program accept that of course
these have been exceptional times we've
never faced anything
like a virus like this before in modern
history yeah and in terms of support in
the cabinet jacob rees-mogg not quite as
in favor of the national insurance rise
uh as others we understand from
yesterday's cabinet meeting how did did
his suggestion that that should be
scrapped the rise go down well
cabinets take place in in in private was
i'm not going to get into commenting on
uh cabinet meeting uh content uh we have
a plan uh it is to catch up on uh on
things like the backlog in uh in nhs uh
care which has come about uh
unfortunately through coronavirus and
that plan is being put into into place
uh you know it is also true to say that
we want to make sure that we relieve tax
pressures uh on public uh as and when we
can but you know that has to be done
line government could change their mind
on this and scrap it
oh well look we're absolutely committed
to doing two things one catching up with
the backlog in the nhs and that's why we
have this national insurance uh increase
for specifically for that purpose and
two sourcing out the long-term issue of
social care where people lose their
homes uh if they have specific types of
illnesses for example dementia uh which
has always seemed to me to be cruel and
unfair particularly when uh you're you
know helped by the nhs if you had
something else and that was eventually
uh the thing which you passed away from
so uh no we're absolutely committed to
making those changes it's an historic
change that i think will bring a lot of
security to families up and down the the
country so we'll certainly be doing that
okay grant chaps good to talk to you
today thank you for joining us me too
thanks very much